welcome back to new rock stars I'm Erik
Voss and the Black Widow movie is the
next big release in the Marvel calendar
the first official installment of Marvel
phase 4 but the big question I think a
lot of us have about it is why is Marvel
kick-starting a thrilling future era
with a prequel about a hero who has no
future [ __ ]
like don't get me wrong I am very
excited for Black Widow particularly for
the ways it might fill in the gap so the
MCU timeline that we know so little
about like all the red in Natasha
Romanovs ledger whatever went down in
Budapest those two years between civil
war and infinity war when everyone made
new hair choices and black widows hair
clock started ticking went blonde huh
has gotta be a story there add that to
the latest news that Robert Downey jr.
is apparently reprising his role as Tony
Stark one final time in the Black Widow
film which can't just be because this is
a Marvel film and on the Black Widow
poster Robert Downey jr. space must
contractually cover like 40% of it no I
think if they are going to bring Tony
Stark back into this story it must be
for a good reason
a critical necessary reason a reason
that this whole movie and its role in
phase four couldn't exist without yes I
am submitting to you the theory that the
Black Widow movie will feature the
resurrection of Natasha Romanov it's a
bit crackpot but I'm gonna break down
all the evidence for this theory and
spoiler warning in case any of this ends
up being too accurate in ruins your life
okay before when we've wondered whether
Black Widow could resurrect from her
tragic sacrifice on Vermeer and Avengers
endgame the screenwriters have suggested
that cap couldn't just toss the sole
stone back over the cliff and get a
refund
Captain America it comes back with the
soul stones of warm air yeah do we get
it Natasha do we get Black Widow back
[Applause]
I doesn't know return huh I don't know
what listen that is not the intent the
intent guys yeah now these in-game
screenwriters Eminem are in disagreement
with their own directors over how
exactly their movie ends so their intent
isn't necessarily considered canon but
let's take them at their word for now
that cap returning the sole soda Boromir
alone doesn't result in black widows
resurrection remember Bruce Banner tried
to snap everyone back and then later he
told cap that he tried to bring Natasha
back to you no I tried when I had to go
with the stones I really tried to bring
her back
I miss him man but banner failed in that
its acquisition requires a blood
sacrifice and that sacrifice cannot be
reversed and it might have to do with
how nebula described for me er the
Dominion of death at the very center of
celestial existence mmm celestial
depending on whether that celestial was
a capital C or a lowercase C the power
of the godly Celestials of the Marvel
Universe might govern the rules of this
sacrifice and cap and banner can't defy
those rules to trade lives but maybe
Tony Stark can Tony's snap at the end of
the film was a near mirror reversal of
Thanos a snap with each member of his
ranks reflecting the deaths of each
Avenger in infinity war it was
essentially a life for a life so I
couldn't Stark have included in his
final snap and amended clause for his
old pound etosha Romanov like think
about it when Hulk and Thanos snapped
with the stones the radiation blast
didn't kill them yet it did kill Stark
could he have used his snap to trade a
life look when this news about Robert
Downey jr. appearing in Black Widow came
out like many of you I felt skeptical
Downey's contract is finished and in
every interview Downey has made it quite
clear that his days playing Iron Man are
over aesthetic distance it's the it's
job one I'm not my work yeah not what I
did with that studio I'm not that period
of time that I spent playing this
character and it sucks because you know
the kid and all of us wants to be like
no it's always going to be summer camp
and we're all holding hands and singing
Kumbaya
isn't it it's like no no snap out of it
no we don't want to snap out of it Papa
Tony we're waving boys we don't want to
watch the freaking judge so it's just
odd to hear from deadlines Jeff boo sure
that daddy will be same in Rolo Stark
one more time however the Maya have a
prequel Black Widow and may 20 29 does
make this possible the story will take
place between civil war in infinity war
in which maybe Natasha as a fugitive
could turn to Tony in a time of need or
for flashbacks set before Natasha join
the Avengers Tony could cameo as his
younger weapons builder playboy self but
why would you drag our DJ back into this
role for a simple cameo like this he had
the perfect send-off an Avengers end
game and our DJ cameos ain't cheap like
for a supporting role in spider-man
homecoming he was paid 10 million
dollars so let's assume that Starks
cameo in Black Widow will be made via
archived footage a deleted scene from a
past film stock footage and let's assume
that they're gonna use that deleted
material for something that will be
meaningful to Natasha Romanoff who let's
be honest didn't really get a proper
send-off an in-game like her goodbye was
relatively quick and heartless spanner
discus pasta [ __ ] boo maybe with this
new Tony Stark scene we could find out
that his sacrifice was even more
meaningful when it came to Natasha's
fate remember shortly after endgame came
out we got those reports of an alternate
Indian scene featuring Tony the moment
of the snap originally he was going to
enter the orange Sol realm the one where
Thanos met young Gamora and their Tony
was going to meet his daughter Morgan
stark as a young woman played by
Catherine Langford now the scene was
removed because test audiences had no
emotional connection to an older version
of Morgan Stark they were like who is
this chick but clearly the filmmakers
wanted to go inside Tony's mind the
moment of this snap also interesting
Marmol did not include this deleted
scene among the other deleted scenes for
the end game blu-ray release that might
be because Marvel Studios has plans to
reuse that footage so what if Robert
Downey jr. is cameo in Black Widow is
taken from this deleted footage of Tony
in the soul realm imagine a post-credits
scene that rolls after the Black Widow
credits like the last of the VFX artists
scroll up and we're all two sitting in
the theater wondering wait wasn't
already Jason but then BAM post credits
scene and we're back at the critical
moment from
of interest endgame in that flash of
white we see Tony in the soul realm
except now it's not Morgan stark that he
sees its Natasha Romanov and within this
SunnyD cosmic limbo Tony decides to make
a bargain now with whom perhaps these
Celestials the beings who might be
behind the rules of the soul stone Tony
says take my life but restore hers and
then the Celestials are like oh that
means we can be done with all this the
noeleen universe bending and time I
mentally and then sure just like fix
this mortal okay then poof Tony dies
shortly after and in the pool of Vermeer
awakens Natasha waiting to be rescued by
like rocket Captain Marvel whoever in
fact according to a recently leaked set
photo from Black Widow taken in Norway
one scene will depict Natasha wading
through a pool holding a glowing object
so if Tony Stark were to return in Black
Widow resurrecting the heroes so that
her film doesn't feel like a pointless
tribute to a long begotten hero this
could be a way they use old footage to
make Tony Stark love us 3001 all if
they're just willing to revisit that
epic snap snap out of it what do you
think Tony Stark's cameo in Black Widow
will be comment down below with your
thoughts follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at the hit that like button and
subscribe to new rock stars for
breakdowns of everything Marvel thank
you for joining me in come on Papa Tony
help us out bring her back
[Music]